-You wrote an op-ed in "The Ne
York Times" talking about
the escalating violence
between Israel and Gaza.
This is a terrible situation
I know that President Bide
reached out
to Benjamin Netanyahu
and urged him to de-escalate
Do you feel like that messag
is getting through,
and do you feel like
President Biden is doing enough?
-I think we need
an immediate cease-fire, Seth.
The situation there
is absolutely terrible.
Just talked to somebody
in Gaza yesterday.
And it's not only
the loss of lives.
Several hundred Palestinians
have been killed.
12 Israelis have been killed
But in Gaza, you are
talking about a situation no
where people
don't have electricity.
They don't have fuel.
They don't have clean water.
Their wastewater plants
have been destroyed,
and fetid excrement is
coming out into the streets.
You have a horrible situation,
and that's built on
the terrible situation
that existed before the conflict
where youth unemployment
was 70%.
So you've got a total disaster
there.
And I think that what the
function of where we should be
especially when we're giving
$4 billion a year to Israel,
is we should be
bringing people together,
not just being one-sided
and saying everything that
Israel does is good,
because it is not.
Over the years,
Netanyahu and his government
have become
much more right wing.
You have overt racists
who are now
part of Netanyahu's coalition,
and what the United States
has got to say is
"Look, it's a difficult
situation.
It's gone on for decades.
No magical answer.
But you guys are going to have
to come together and develop
a long-term plan
that provides dignity
for the Palestinian people
safety for the Israeli people.
We've got to be pro-Israel
We've got to be pro-Palestinian.
But I think just being one-sided
is wrong,
and it is not productive
in terms of
bringing peace to the region
-You know, one of the things
you write about,
and I think on a human level
we can all agree
that everyone, be they
Palestinian, be they Israeli
deserves safety,
deserves security.
And they have a right to that.
You denounce Hamas.
Obviously no one is on the sid
of shooting rockets into Israel.
But the Palestinians
have been let down
by Hamas as a government.
And Hamas does not represent
all Palestinians in the same way
that Benjamin Netanyahu
does not represent all Israelis.
One of the things that becomes
really fraught is that
when people criticize
the Israeli government,
it can somehow -- and sometimes,
I should say instead of
somehow -- can sometimes
be framed as anti-Semitic.
How do we have these
conversations, making it clear
to our Jewish friends
or Jewish family that
this is not anti-Semitism to b
specifically critical abou
steps or actions
that a government makes?
-Anti-Semitism is a very serious
issue and it's a growing issue
in the United States
and around the world.
But criticizing the government
of Israel does not make yo
anti-Semitic anymore
than it makes you pro-Hama
if you talk about
the terrible destruction
now taking place in Gaza.
Look, we have -- Trump is gone
And I hope to see a new face
in our foreign policy,
and that is an approach that
brings the world together
and understands that we got to
deal with climate change.
We got to get the vaccines out
to poor countries
around the world.
We should be
leading that effort.
And in the Middle East,
it is difficult, Seth.
I mean, good people
have worked on this issue
for decades without success.
But the current situation
is unsustainable.
If you have massive misery and
70% youth unemployment in Gaza
do you not --
do you doubt for a second
that there will be
more and more unrest?
So we have got to figure out
a way to bring
Israel
and the Palestinians together.
Understand that Hamas is not
only a terrorist organization.
It is. It is corrupt.
It is ineffective.
And they do not reflect,
I think,
the wishes of
the Palestinian people.
And in Israel,
to complicate the problem,
you have a government more and
more right wing under Netanyahu.
So this is not easy stuff,
but as the most powerful natio
on Earth,
we've got to do our best
to bring people together
and finally bring peace
to that troubled region.
-I would like to stress as well,
it's very easy to talk about i
from behind a desk here.
And I certainly don't thin
it's easy, and I send my wishe
to everyone living through tha
terrible time in that region
I want to ask,
you were our first guest
when we started doing our show
from home during the summe
and everybody was spending
more time at home.
Did you get to spend time
with your grandkids?
Was this a good year
at least on that topic?
-Well, yes and no.
For three of the kids
who live in Pennsylvania,
I have not been
able to see them.
For the kids who live in
Burlington, we are getting -
Yes, the answer is
we have seen them,
and now that the masks
are beginning to come off,
it's a much better situation
yeah, for all of us.
I mean, we have gone through
a terrible year,
and hopefully we're going to see
some better times.
-Did the grandkids
enjoy the memes?
-Yes, they did.
They all saw them.
They all knew about it.
-Alright, well, I feel lik
we've talked about
some really tough stuff today,
so I want to show you
some of my favorites.
This is --
Did you see "The Sopranos"
Did you see that one?
-Oh, God.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a really good one.
I like the subway.
I feel like that's exactly how
you would sit on the subway.
-[ Laughs ]
-This one is very --
This is some very fine art
This is you as a member of
the Justice Society.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know if you see yourself
up there.
And this one -- I think
my favorite one about you here
with Anna Wintour and Cardi
'cause it's like, "Ha-ha,
how funny would it be if Berni
Sanders was next to Cardi B?
But, of course, you and Cardi
are friends.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-So the real joke here
is this one is --
Of all of them, this one
is the most likely to be real.
-Yeah, except the last tim
I saw her,
I wasn't wearing
a mask or mittens.
-[ Laughs ]
Well, better times.
Hopefully the next time too.
It's always a pleasure.
Hey, thanks so much
for making time for us.
And it's just always a pleasur
to talk to you.
-Thanks so much, Seth.
See you soon.
-Alright, we'll see you soon
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."